so if you are not utilizing the XYZ
method in your resume
let's talk XYZ as recruiters as hiring
managers we want to know what you did
how did you do it and what were the
results x what did you accomplish plus
why what was the qualitative result plus
Z what skills or experience did you
utilize to achieve that outcome that is
what's going to stand out to the
employer who's reading your resume so
it's not just what did you do in your
role what impact did you have so say
you're in college right and maybe you
were part of sorority so did you manage
a sorority budget or did you manage 52
000 of a sororities budget in 2019 where
you then took and invested idle funds
back into the appropriate High yielding
Capital notes
which sounds better all right friends so
if you are not hearing back from any
jobs that you're applying for
this could be a big reason why
[Music]